up next is gonna be Chris in North
Carolina hey Chris welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey gentlemen how are y'all
awesome how can we help my wife is
pregnant he is due in September we have
Paul's baby step number two and good
it's a pile of toys good
should we pause paying on my student
loans which is at the end of our baby
step two since it won't be accruing
interest with President Trump raising
interest doing this pandemic yes okay
yeah I would pay well we tell people
when you say pause as you pay minimum
payments on everything and if they're
allowing I haven't looked at the details
on the Trump edict on this but if they
are saying you don't have any have to
make payments on your student loans then
don't make payments on them the last
time I checked it said that that we may
not have interest well you're gonna have
some kind of payment well I did hear I
haven't seen anything that he was
talking about suspending payment or we
they've talked about will meals
I mean they've talked about everything
so you can't go by what they're talking
about all you can do go by is what they
actually do and that's both of them the
house and the Senate approving it and
the president signing it then we have
what's called a law the rest of its
called politics and BS that's exactly
right Chris what I would do is reach out
call your your loan servicer wherever
you send your payment Act to call them
talk with them to find out exactly where
they are where they stand
just because they are talking about it
as dave mentions not all of those
student loan providers have to sign on
or may agree to that so I want you to
reach out to your servicer find out
directly for yourself if they mandate it
and it's a federally insured they will
have to go along with it but I don't
think it's law yet and I doubt it's
gotten down to their service centers yet
I would make my payments for right now
okay if you can find out saw if and if
it becomes a solid piece of information
that is the truth that is law it's
probably going to be 30 to 60
before you actually can get that in
print and then you get on the phone with
the servicer and you cut off the making
payments if you can legally stop making
payments or interest rate without
causing yourself a problem well yes I
would do that and just have that much
more cash you're going to turn right
around and plow it back into debt after
she comes home and baby comes home and
everybody's fine in September so it's
just between now and September that
matters anyway because you're gonna keep
you're gonna get back in gear and get
everything paid as fast as you can get
it paid that's right now let me also
tell everybody there is no student loan
ferry and there's no mortgage ferry so
when you hear the government talking
about doing this all they're doing is
extending the period of indebtedness
right so you're just gonna add that
payment to the end of the of the loan so
it's not like you've gotten anything
free I just I wanted I had to say that
Dave as everybody's thinking that it's
just this free pass and it's not